allo arthur c'est ta mère tu te souviens
de moi maintenant c'est drôle j'étais
sur le point de ta part tu c'est drôle
j'avais la main sur le titre
je me disais tiens les mac les roms
jeudi dernier moi je t'assure j'ai pas
une seconde
parce que je suis resté à côté du
téléphone toute la journée de vendredi
l'agencé de maîtrise mais oui mais je me
suis dit faut la jouer
la journée du dimanche rio perdu des
mange mange quelque chose sinon tu ne
tueras pas le coma et ne pas avoir d'un
but plein de mamans on équipe et moi on
envoyait saturn 6 dans l'espace la fusée
je venais entendu parler eh bien c'était
la mise à feu samedi
oui je sais il ya toujours une bonne
raison arthur prête à parier que tous
les autres savants qui travaille avec
toi honte une mère je suis certaine
qu'ils trouvent tous un moment entre
leur petit déjeuner ou avant le compte à
l'envers amour écoute ça y est
maintenant le seul à au bout du fil à
leur écoute bien que je me fais du souci
et je sais j'ai lu dans le journal que
vous arrêtez pas de les perdre ont fusé
oui je suis pas tout seul c'est pas moi
qui les perd j'avais peur contre les
retiennent sur ton salaire
une petite loutre un mot il ya une carte
efforts de moi sur coup des coûts
dis-moi comment tu vas comme moi tu vas
mal
ah bon que tu vas pas rien c'est bien ce
qui ne va pas comme d'habitude mais j'ai
vu le médecin radio une mata ménages il
m'a dit écoutez madame zacharias faut
pas se leurrer regardons les choses en
face
vous êtes une femme extrêmement nerveux
extrêmement nerveuse et je ne supporte
pas la moindre contrariété
j'ai dit docteur je sais bien mobilier
ou les joueurs mais il a beaucoup
travaillé beaucoup vraiment mais qu'est
ce que vous voulez ils sont soit le
temps la place à vraiment tu étais les
vieux viens de te tue je n'exagère pas
quand je lui ai dit ça il a blêmi sa
carrière ça fait trente ans que je
pratique la médecine première fois que
l'autre parler d'un fils qui n'a pas eu
le temps d'appeler sa mère qui l'a dit
arthur et c'est un docteur en écoute dix
mois le médecin est-il a décidé à qu'est
ce qui va faire j'irai peut-être
l'hôpital un petit moment à l'hôpital
oui à l'hôpital mais qu'est ce qu'ils
vont faire qu'est ce que tu veux qu'il
fasse les radios de mes nerfs
ecoutez jean tu aimerais me donne mais
un jour arthur tout manera et tuera des
enfants et mon chéri je ne souhaite
qu'une chose c'est que tu es enfant tu
vas souffrir autant que toi tu m'as fait
sombrer et comme un non merci d'avoir
rappelé que moi je fais ce que je peux
tu m'appelles moi je sais que c'est
casey je suis dans city 2
j'espère seulement que je ne t'ai pas
trop déprimé par bien tu m'a déprimé
renchérit si c'était vrai je serai la
plus heureuse des mères je remercie
pourquoi tu m'appelles jamais du nom qui
ne serait ce que tu veux je suis une
mère possessive 90 jours et j'avais des
soucis coutume apple pas est ce que
c'est vraiment trop te demander de
prendre le téléphone s'il te plaît mais
moi je te promettre très content je suis
très content hassi bahbah beaucoup de
succès avec des petites fusées
sinon merci maman aime tellement son
grand garçon actuelle beaucoup beaucoup
à petit mon grand moment là
m